oh hey PJ how's it going glad you could
make it once again yeah no it was a
quite a trek but I made it last time I
lost [ __ ] this one [ __ ] me you recommend
it today you reckon dude correct but I
got a new challenge for you PG whoa what
do you know by weekend I spend hours
studying wikiHow this is how you're so
good at fetish adjust to everything yes
this is how I accomplish everything at
life okay so we're we get the picture of
a wikiHow article but we have to guess
whoa sorry I appreciate that you're
saying I'm just trying to just trying to
be enthusiastic for you know it's hard
to get enthusiastic over over this will
guess the title bar on the result rolls
the loser has to highlight our hair
that's not actually too bad that
actually not that fun I could do like
yeah I could you're bald so oh wow
didn't need to see that go well this is
clearly how to walk from A to B wait I
sorry I forgot to tell you you you could
actually like oh there's a choice yeah
how do you get unless that would have
helped okay
what the [ __ ] this isn't any of these
things Oh
or is it okay I'm gonna I'm just gonna
guess because what the [ __ ] is this game
what is this what whoa that was right
but that didn't make any sense can we
play a game that makes a shut up
don't I know this guy this is your how
to prevent identity theft by mailing a
fish to someone how to catch a cheating
girlfriend by mailing a fish to how to
find a husband when the women outnumber
the men in the country
how to choose a rigorous college
schedule for your first I think no no no
nope
yeah no grab a place that was how to
prevent identity theft so upset
how to choose a puppy Oh how to succeed
in a relationship with the perfect girl
uh yeah how's that yeah this seems very
very this thing's like a very well
balanced relationship I'm seeing here
how to keep dogs off the lawn how to
make lemonade when life gives you lemons
oh it's a nightmare
oh it is harder than the [ __ ] game I
yeah what is this alright I'm just gonna
give it this cuz this seems the most it
doesn't seem logical though I'm gonna
whoa how do you always got it right like
I said I've been studying wikiHow for a
while now and yeah just you [ __ ] nerd
yeah well oh oh
they mess with these dudes oh wow - ooh
wow that guy looks so cool how to tell
if you genuinely like someone
No how do I ask her for a dance with a
baseball bat
hey girl hey guy you won't go for damn
you wanna dance with me I got a beret
you better dance
uh-huh dude in Jews nightmare yeah this
is pretty not to be a punk slammin but
that was pretty [ __ ] easy how to have
snakes that's your head he's got a load
of pewdiepies on his head cuz oh because
I'm a snails Felix is a snake how to
visit I thought it said lasagna Beach
Laguna Beach California how to catch a
cheating girlfriend what's he thinking
what is in his mind
I think this might be my point my point
my point this is ridiculous of you how
to disappear like a ninja
no oh yeah you didn't do it [ __ ] you
well how was this Felix huh if you're so
good at wikiHow coffee Felix hit us up
what is this don't face flying off you
what is this how'd it be a park get
clearly how to pick up girls in high
school know how to have a successful
open source project I imagine that
that's what that feels like it's to
scream open source to me how to have fun
without friends seems like the only one
I mean but it does still doesn't fit for
hey you won't even need to read the
article they ask you how you are you say
that you're fine well how about I select
that one then ah [ __ ] it what why am i
cheering I'm not winning are you no no
you have won up to me oh great that's
good tonight I mean this is pro tip line
these articles this is probably a type
of pornography it's not one I would want
to read but in a I mean you're the one
they know all the fetishes yep again
it's not any of these how to talk to
girls how to [ __ ] know how to disappear
like a ninja no this is easy this is
easy let me tell you okay how to love
your girlfriend [ __ ] it was how to make
lemonade when life gives you lemons
obviously dammit dammit Felix
[ __ ] how to cheese the press how to kill
yourself how to read how to rip your
throat out in one easy movement how to
decide if you should become a stripper
how to catch a cheating girlfriend how
to act like one of the gun
is how to clear a stuffing I think it's
cheating girlfriend it must be cheating
dammit
that one was so obvious my point uh how
to enjoy phone sex
oh he's enjoying himself what is joy de
vivre
you don't what you don't know where you
tell me you know this guy doesn't know
what joyed what is it pj rivers oh man
it would blow your mind come on tell me
it would I did knew all along you knew a
lot long hid in his point my point oh
whoa I got the sexy one I find this one
how to act silly with your boyfriend how
to find a husband when the woman
outnumber the men in your country how to
show your husband that you love him
how to turn a girl on ooh tricky tricky
I think silly I think I can silly know
how to dream of cricket are you gonna
run away from home yeah yeah I'm running
away I think that's it yeah go for it
why not don't even read the other one
how to be interesting you might need to
read that at school Felix they ask you
how you are you say that you're fine
you're not really fine you just can't
get into it because they would how to
I'm run away from home oh is it the [ __ ]
are these pictures how to [ __ ] get
possessed man when I grow up I wanna
draw pictures from vici huh how to
survive domestic violence how to have
Jehovah's Witnesses go away they are a
pain in the ass when they come from your
belly how to talk dirty in bed how to
survive a coyote attack I always
wondered if using your belly ghost would
work on a coyote attack or not yeah I
know it doesn't trust me oh I don't know
what is he doing I compared the
situation he is Pepe J why is he what is
this he why is he partly see-through as
well you can see the rocks that he's
even not even sitting oh yeah you're
mrs. drew there's an error in the
drawing no I don't know maybe domestic
violence but yeah [ __ ] it yes my point
slamming so what she's saying sex safely
move it forward yeah just how to know if
your girlfriend wants to have sex with
you well if she says I think it might be
how to get rid of an unwanted erection
yeah I've just got a really good feeling
about this unn what a good feeling I got
a good feeling too I've never felt this
good about night anytime I want to get
rid of my erection I just asked a girl
to yell sex at me okay yeah whatever I
got weird
yes I mean that's not you can't really
how would I possibly know Thank You vici
how article for illustrating so well and
I spit on the screen thank you
we're gonna have to do whoever loses
next one it's [ __ ] out Jesus cross
counter you got you got this PJ Allah I
did not lose count I did not I got this
I got this what's she doing she's just
smiling how to feed a snake that's it
that's it figured you got this my
destiny is closed you increase your head
why
how to be pretty how to play with a pen
well there's no pets involved there is
no ejaculate involved and there are no
snakes involved so by process of
elimination I'm gonna guess it's how to
be pretty if you think that's pretty I
mean go right ahead
dude the human form is pretty yes
slamming [ __ ] you get out of the way
drop in something whoa that's pretty
that's the real how to be pretty yeah
how to dress up like a hillbilly how to
lose your virginity way today I'd pain I
hope that's not how it looks like how to
play wink murder how to be comfortable
with your own skin oh no yep it was
clearly how to dress up like a hillbilly
Felix you know well that means double
now come along yeah tell me what I wanna
hear
by the power vested in me I didn't that
Pedro is the ringer [ __ ] thanks governor
Oh mammy and gobble we wish broke out
for a drink sometime you know thank you
oh wow oh [ __ ] gaba come on god damn it
do I really have to go okay what color
do you want I mean blue was a massive
failure is there any other color that
you upset what what was that
is there any other color you've got a
preference for does Google have a
preference he said pink pink oh I get
little gloves all right what okay Felix
bend over please never done this before
you're like a sexy anime schoolgirl
you don't know how to do highlights
course oh no I know how it is I mean not
that I would know yeah well what did you
just do
I'm trying to apply I think we need
water Oh
hey could you do like a rainbow I could
try I mean that'd be cool yeah this this
is us right now PJ you know that
everyone's gonna just say oh your copy
and markiplier with the with the red
hair no I got it first
mark okay what this isn't like it's not
my collar no I think I mean it's good
but I think if you want to go rainway
we're gonna need some red as well I can
do red oh that's not oh that what that's
no effective I'm gonna look great you're
gonna be super so super jealous
yeah I think we're nearly just about
done here let's try to make sure how
much are you putting in well you said
you wanted a lot right you say no I did
not say that what the [ __ ]
okay okay yeah that's pretty high feels
weird yeah I think I was pretty it's my
best work yeah was it the first time we
played I did a way face tattoos then we
do ah no I hope this washes out we've
got another 1/2 [ __ ] assist permanent
for light right here well PJ always a
pleasure isn't it oh yeah I love it I
thank you for coming over when we doing
this next okay well check out PJ I'll
leave a link in the description thing
thank you yeah that roll man any time
any time any literally literally don't
know why I challenge you at a [ __ ]
guessing game yeah I'm good at thee I'm
to get it I will get you one day PG
[Music]